thank you kade and good morning and as
ksa thank you for being here after a
long day
uh but this is uh really important work
and
before i get started i'd like to thank
uh the members
of the committee and the task force
and the commission that has put together
this uh report
under our chief of human resources ms
nadine jones um as she
chaired this work um this kind of gives
you a little bit of a back story and
where this started
this has been something that as you as a
district that some of you have been
covering this for
a while the school system we've had an
issue and really
been recruiting and retaining our
educators we've had
a number amount of teachers that um
making positions in our schools for day
one i'm coming in i knew that
when i took this job two and a half
years ago um
and and really was set a clear focus to
hopefully uh our goal and target by
by the end of our strategic plan is that
we minimize
and we have a zero vacancies in our
school so every child
has an opportunity to learn and grow
with a highly qualified and certified
teacher
in every um every classroom
right now when you'll see in the report
is that potentially
we have around um you know twelve
percent
of our of our classroom i mean twelve
thousand students that do not have
um experience that experience on day one
so this commission i just wanted to
thank you for your work and looking at
all the data
and looking at all our previous
practices and bring some
really um extensive recommendations for
for me and the team to align to the to
the work moving forward
this is very similar to the equity
commission that was that was delivered
and shared with us
a year ago this is not going to be
something that we are going to be
putting on the shelf
this is not something that is just
another report to tell us a lot of the
things that we already know this is a
report that is really going to be action
driven
and i'm excited that this team will
deliver on some of what these
recommendations
um before i turn it over to
our next dr brenda pearson from cca i
really do want to thank cca
as our exclusive collective bargaining
agent
um i say this often they're not um you
know there's a lot of
other districts of my colleagues across
the country that
may not have such a great collaborative
partnership i believe that we do because
we have the same vision and having a
highly qualified certified teacher is
the number one predictor for student
success
and we are both aligned um
on that mission and i want to thank her
and the team but also my seven bosses
and my board of trustees that we will be
that will be holding me accountable
and our team to deliver on this result
so dr pearson
yeah thank you very much thank you
superintendent jara
i was honored to be part of this
commission so thank you for inviting me
just to recap in order for ccsd to
recruit a high quality teaching force
we have to first start with attracting
candidates to the profession
the commission identified hurdles to
recruit
to recruitment and developed
recommendations aimed at meeting the
goals
identified by ccsd in the 2024 plan the
first hurdle we identified
was the recruitment we need to have a
stronger teacher pipeline right now our
pipeline is too limited to do that we
need to work
collaboratively with local universities
and partners
currently there's a third of all of our
ccsd annual hires come from outside of
nevada
in order to reverse that trend
we want to make sure that we expand the
grow your own programs that
exposes future educators to the
profession
ccsd's teacher pipeline also needs to be
more diverse
this is simple we know that it is
important
because when students learn from
educators who identify
as the same race their learning outcomes
improve
also our community has a built-in
pipeline of teachers already
with the support professionals and our
students in the career and tech
academies
this needs to be strengthened the second
hurdle we identified was the hiring
process
and we had recommendations that were
three-fold the first we need to start
hiring earlier
this allows ccsd to be one of the first
folks out of the gate
prior to the other districts to recruit
high quality teachers
next we need to be forward thinking and
we need to use data to project the
number of teaching
positions and types of positions we need
for the next year
we need to create candidate pools to
make sure that future ccsd educators
move through the process
more smoothly those are our
recommendations that we came up with
for the recruitment of teachers to ccsd
michelle would you like to add anything
to uh what dr person
yeah thank you i was going to bring it
and and
thank you thank you um dr pearson one of
the things that i do
want to also recognize is we did get
partners we received um some support
from our business community
um not only was the metro chamber and
some of the
our partners and nonprofits but then
also experts in the hr
and i know that michelle has extensive
uh michelle detondo has extensive
background
in um in hr practices and hiring
practices from our our partners here
within the business community so
michelle anything that you want to share
and end
into this recommendation sure
thank you for the opportunity to serve
on the commission i was actually on the
retention subcommittee so if the
recruitment
committee was focused on how do we fill
the pipeline retention was focused on
how do we keep it from
leaking so that we can gain some
progress
the report will show that about 12
percent of year one teachers leave the
school district after their first year
and um 14.9 percent of experienced
teachers
resign for reasons other than uh
retirement and so we knew that there
were some challenges that we needed to
understand in order to address retention
as we dove
into trying to find out the reasons why
teachers at all experience levels would
choose to leave either a school or the
district
what we really found out was we needed
to improve
our data in order to ensure we were
focusing on the right things
so our first recommendation was that we
improve upon the
existing culture survey which identifies
challenges that leaders or teachers face
and
feedback that they might have on the
culture of their buildings
and then second expand the exit
survey to include all teachers
whether they're in their first year or
whether they're experienced teacher
and identify why they either leave their
building or why they resign from the
school district so we can make sure that
we understand and address what's driving
those decisions
the second recommendation that we have
and that we know
is that the roles of both teachers and
administrators
are complex and challenging and so we
wanted to improve the coaching and
mentoring
programs that are offered within the
school district for
teachers at all experience levels not
just new teachers who
are learning the role but experienced
teachers who continue to face
challenges along with their
administrators and so our second
recommendation
was to improve upon coaching and
mentoring programs within the
district to support teachers and
administrators with all the challenges
they faced
so with that uh we also have uh
ccsd's chief of human resources nadine
jones on the line we're going to open it
up for questions
um we're going to start with television
first we'll start with channel three
channel three do you have any
any questions
not hearing any fox5 do you have any
any questions you'd like to ask
all right channel 8.
you have any questions
hello dr jar and everyone else out of
curiosity
is this also a way to improve our the
number of students in our classes
because
we have been dealing with um
over overcrowded classrooms so the
reason you're trying to recruit more
teachers is to help deal with the
overcrowding in our classrooms and is
this a way to also prepare
for future school years or whether it's
2021 2022 or
2024 and beyond to make sure our class
sizes are reduced and we have more
teachers to support that
i'll turn it over to i miss nadine jones
hi good good morning everyone nadine
jones um
you know truly the the motivation was
more about
um just filling the current classes that
we have and ensuring that for the
current classes that we have
that we have a teacher in every
uh classroom at the beginning of the
school year and of course ongoing
um so it was really more about that than
it was specifically related to
class size reduction okay
and how what is our teacher shortage
right now
in the district so as
of uh yesterday um
we were 269 classroom teachers
short
it that seems significant because i
think in previous years we've been
talking about 700
800 so why is it different this year
compared to previous years
so you are correct it is definitely a
significant change
just to put it into a little bit more
context the beginning of the 1920 school
year
i believe our reported number was
approximately 761
classroom shortages this year at the
very beginning of the year we opened up
with
409 classroom
shortages a lot of the reason for that
was
our retention rate or attrition rate was
lower so we had less people leave the
district
less classroom teachers leave the
district last year
as compared to prior years so definitely
the focus on retention
that michelle spoke about you know we
can see
what the what a significant difference
that makes uh so i do believe that that
was a large part of the
the reason for the reduction
animal 13 ktmv
i don't know if max is on or not
all right let's go to print uh review
journal
hello i'm i was wondering if someone
could please address the challenges
in recruiting certified teachers to come
to ccsd
and what subject areas or grade levels
in particular are you seeing
the most challenges
so yes i can address that um really
a large part of the challenge in
recruiting is what dr
brenda pearson said is that the we the
pipelines are just not
full enough so even from uh local
universities and colleges of education
there are not enough people going into
education not enough people graduating
from education in order to fill the need
and as i'm sure you're all aware it's
also a national
issue so it's not that specifically is
not unique
to nevada in terms of the
subject areas special education
is almost always the largest
opportunity area for us to fill and then
some of the other
areas are elementary
math and science but special education
is
is by far the most challenging
do you have any other additional
questions julie
uh no that answers my question thank you
is anybody from the las vegas sun
on the call yes
this is sarah mcneill las vegas sun
how many teachers have left the school
district
since march
so i don't have the exact number from
march
i'm sure i could get it but we i tend to
look at it more you know for the cycle
of the whole school year
um again i don't have the hard number
but i can tell you as a percentage
of licensed professionals normally we're
approximately nine percent
that leave us annually and that's
including experienced teachers
and new hires so that's and not just
classroom that's
all licensed professionals it's
generally about nine percent
um and this past year so ending with the
1920 school year we were at
um roughly seven percent so
by percentages i can tell you i would
have to look up the exact numbers if you
need hard numbers
okay so um the pandemic how has it
impacted um retention
and recruitment
um so you know
that number that i just told you that
seven percent attrition was for all of
last school year and as you know the
pandemic
we our first closure was in march so i
would say
it has you know potentially
because of the um
lack of other employment opportunities
just with the downturn
in the economy as a result of the
pandemic i believe more people
chose to stay it's a secure um
and definitely needed uh position and so
for us as our experience here at ccsd
thus far
it has um not had a negative impact on
our retention
in terms of recruitment certainly we are
not able to travel as we did previously
to um you know uh colleges of education
um in other states but we have of course
adapted as everyone else has to
uh online virtual affairs and you know
more of that type of
activity um so so far
it's nothing really significant
in terms of the impact of ccsd for
recruitment and retention
okay thank you so much and uh just one
more thing i wanted someone said that
vacancies in classrooms means that like
a class wouldn't have
a teacher there uh it would just be
so i i'm just wondering how you deal
with that are the teachers
um doing two classes or
how is that working uh in
most cases it would be covered by a
substitute
guest teacher in most cases okay
thank you that's all you're welcome
thanks uh max i see your hand we'll
circle back to tv in a second
uh digital mr huey
good morning thank you for taking my
question eric hughie with clark county
school
watch first question i do have a
follow-up
um with this report where
does it go from here what's the end
result
is this going to go to the board for
discussion and possible action where
where do we see the end result of
uh this uh report so
um i'll answer that question um mr huey
this is
a report that i as the superintendent
commissioned
so this is within the purview of my
operations
from outside folks looking into the
recommendations i've accepted the report
this was shared yesterday with a preview
for our partners so we will as alignment
to the strategic plan we will be moving
forward with implementing the
recommendations we will share this
publicly with the board
and with the community so the community
is fully aware
of some of the next steps and action
steps but this is something that
my very capable chief of human resources
will be implementing across the district
great and uh just a follow-up um
we obviously were successful in getting
subs
raises for the first time in 20 years uh
how are we doing
uh and this is possibly for ms jones how
are we doing with
trying to convert those subs to
full-time teachers
um there's a there's ongoing discussions
street chatter on social media about
subs wanting to possibly get
benefits to try to get them to stay we
saw a lot of subs
leave as a result of the pandemic so how
are we
working with our substitute uh
population
to uh to try to hold on to those subs
and possibly convert them to
uh full-time teaching positions
thank you that's a great question and
it's actually definitely something that
is a part of our plan to
help close our teacher shortage gap we
do recognize
that we need to do more focused efforts
with
our substitute guest teacher population
those who are of course interested
to move into a full-time role also
our support professionals who are
already working in classrooms side by
side by
with teachers um and many of whom are
interested
in moving into roles and then of course
our students who are in
teach academy programs so um i
think i would answer my question by
saying that um
i do not feel that we are in a great
place with that yet in terms of having a
really good systemic process to help
with that
but i would definitely say it is
something that we are working on setting
up the foundation
for because we absolutely recognize that
that's an opportunity for us as well and
and for that would greatly benefit our
substitute guest teacher population
great thank you that's all i have
uh max you had your hand up
channel 13. channel 3. thanks so much
no worries we're all friends out here
it's all good uh
dr pajara this you have these
recommendations you've that
you'll be moving forward with
implementing the recommendations
how does that process look how do you
implement them in an efficient and
effective way
so that the district can see a
difference soon
yeah max uh thank you for um that
question that's a very important
question actually
you know and this is something that i
failed to mention at the beginning
um you know when we started when i
formed this um
this commission together it was
pre-coded
but this is so critical because whether
we're virtual distance ad blended
face-to-face
we have a teacher shortage and we are
going to need teachers right so it's a
priority about
for us as a school district so one of
the things that
um as things were rolling out um and we
saw the drafts
um of some of the recommendations coming
we started acting on it for example and
i'll give you an example
was we noticed that in the school system
for many years
uh we were only surveying teachers that
were leaving zero to three
to try to find out why well nadine
took the leadership and proactively said
superintendent here's a recommendation
up and the recommendation came from the
commission that we need to survey
every employee leaving the school
district to find out the root causes to
the why
that work started january 4th so we
didn't wait until today
um we didn't wait until today on the
release we started
you know saying everybody in january 4th
from now on so now we survey every
employee
so as we think about some of the most
immediate now it'll be up to the team
to not prioritize now we're in a hiring
season
right so now we start prioritizing some
of those recommendations that we need to
act quickly
um to make sure that we we close the gap
for our classrooms
and just one follow-up with the
uncertainty of the pandemic with the
uncertainty of what the future of
education is going to look like
and the national teacher shortage as is
you've had issues with recruitment
before
why should a teacher who there's not a
lot of
them out there right now anyway why
should they go to ccsd where
there are other options possible they're
on the table flip no you're right
and you know one of the things that we
have to we we certainly
are looking at um is how do we
capitalize on the pandemic and this is
some of the things that and i think it's
in the in the recommendations in the
report
you know we talked about it yesterday um
you know as a team
so we we have magnets we have science
engineering magnets we have science
magnets we have all
so we how do we then expand to build our
own and ccsd so
our kids our families we educate
and and really get into that reward of
of putting you know in changing lives
you know we know
you know we know we don't you know
educators go into
because they want to change the lives of
a child and i think that's the critical
component in the culture
um if you know and that's where we need
to really get into
they don't certainly education they
don't go into it for the money
they go into for the impact that's
happening in the classroom
and the impact that's having in the
child's life and i think that's what we
have to sell about
the security being home knowing your
community and how do we diversify the
options and i think that's in the report
we have to build our own here
in clark county thank you dr john
uh fox5kvpu
what are some of the qualities the
district looks for in a teacher
maybe
so um you know a lot of it is really
um and i don't know the technical side
i've never been a teacher myself so i i
will talk about some of the other
qualities outside of sort of the more
technical uh pieces of it but
some of the qualities and the
information that i've received from the
principles and the things that are of
most importance to them
is truly first and foremost people who
believe that all
students can learn i mean that's
something that i've heard over and over
is how
important it is that we have
educators and really all of our staff
that are in it as dr jar said for the
right reason because they want to make a
difference and because they truly
believe in the ability of
of children um and um that they
they really want to make make that
difference um
so that's literally the the top thing
that i'm always thinking of people who
who genuinely like children who
genuinely care for them who genuinely
want to make a difference and who
have that strong belief that every
student has the ability to succeed
and then just another follow-up with
that uh what would you say to a teacher
who is considering leaving the district
uh well certainly of course first and
foremost part of the reason
for implementing the exit survey is we
want to understand why that's the very
first step is to understand the why
um you know as with any organization
sometimes people leave for really truly
uncontrollable reasons right families
relocating all of those things
if it were a reason
anything to do with you know
dissatisfaction with the district or
anything like that then of course our
next step would be to
work to resolve those things because we
we want to retain our teachers and
ensure that we are meeting their needs
not just our teachers we
really want to retain all of our staff
and ensure
as an employer it's our responsibility
to ensure that we're we're meeting their
needs
um so i would just want to understand
why and if it's something that is within
our control
to um to address then
of course i would ask for the
opportunity for us to address that for
them
okay thank you uh channeling kristen do
you have any follow-up
so just to clarify uh teachers who were
new to about three years in they were
originally given that exit survey about
why they were leaving
and now you expanded it that's correct
okay and then i know dr dr you mentioned
that teachers get into
teaching because of the love of
education but
one thing we've noticed it's you know
the economy runs around
money and i know there isn't a lot of
money however
how do you expect to get teachers here
if you're not offering a competitive
salary and do you think
you can offer a competitive salary
kristin that's a great question
and and i'll say this i think our salary
is competitive i think the challenge
is the class size is uh when you look at
i mean obviously you look at the cost of
living and
we have a competitive salary when we
look at the the components of the class
size when we look at the
lack of instructional materials and lack
of the support and this is where the
partnership with cca is so
so critical um you know in some
it's how do we lower class size because
we do have the largest class size in the
country i'm glad you brought up that
question it's really we have to address
the immediate need of the vacancies but
we certainly
when you when you look at the classroom
space it's a huge issue it's a workload
it's the working conditions
of the teacher that is one of our
biggest barriers and challenges for
recruiting and we don't have the data
so we needed to get to that aspect of of
to see the data as
if this is a component for them to leave
so then we can then partner
and go to the legislature and say here
is what we are hearing from our
educators who are leaving
um because it's it's a plethora um
of issues that we may be we don't know
we can only speculate i think this will
help us
and lastly addressing overcrowding if
you are able to recruit more teachers
do you think that will lower our class
sizes
if we can recruit more teachers to fill
our vacancies and then we have the space
in our buildings because we do have some
overcrowded schools and we have
you know some bacon where we have some
vacancies it's just not the perfect
match so can we can i answer um
specifically
um that yes can we reduce class size it
all depends on where they are
i mean obviously working with our
building leaders with enrollment and how
do we balance that so it's it's a
it's a puzzle uh that we certainly but
as i mentioned in the dean mentioned our
first priority is to have
all our classroom um space uh with a
certified highly qualified classroom
teacher
so that means ccsd will continue to put
in that waiver
to um have those large class sizes
still uh right now i mean when you look
at our numbers
and our enrollment decreased a little
bit
we're certainly going to have to and but
i don't know how many include school
buildings at this point
yeah because we have how many students
would you estimate we have at this point
don't quote me on it but it's around 310
12 000 kids
okay thank you
thank you uh channel 13.
okay uh julie did you have a follow-up
sarah did you have a follow-up
yes yes i did have a follow-up
um based on information gathered
from the exit surveys what are some of
the reasons why
teachers are leaving
so um we have just implemented it as dr
jarrar said
less than two weeks ago it's something
that actually one of the things that the
commission recommended
because they understood that it would
take a while to get you know
sufficient data to take action on so one
of the things the commission
recommended is to potentially send out
the exit survey
to people who have left within the prior
year
so that we could sort of get some you
know
enough uh quantity of data that it would
be meaningful um
within two weeks it's we don't have that
many teachers leave us in a two-week
space
in order to report out on that yet
okay yeah i was confused about that you
said january but
um so the surveys then
when will you have more results from
those surveys do you think are you going
to
review them at the end of the year or
when
so um definitely we'll look at it um
uh closely quarterly just to be able to
see the trending but
it would have the most meaning
towards the end of the school year
because most often
people leave after they've completed
their contract uh
for the next school year so we tend to
have a larger number of
uh exits from the district you know at
the end of the school year
as they're leaving and not intending to
return for the following school year so
that
would be when we would have the largest
uh influx of
data um and i know this is about
recruitment and retention but i do think
that this
should relate i just wanted to see if i
could get it
on the vaccine and whether teachers will
get that
whether teachers will be required to
have that
so teachers will not be required
to have it however we are um working
with
local health officials in order to um
get the logistics together for the
educator pod
okay uh thank you thanks sarah uh
before we get to spanish language i
don't know eric if you have a follow-up
or
if you are okay just one uh real quick
follow-up thank you
um dr how many sat on the commission
what was the makeup
of the commission the the
the level of diversity with educators or
support staff
that uh sat on the commission if you
will
uh i don't have that i think that's in
the report but we had uh
i would say not to quote me on this eric
i think
uh it's on the report and we'll release
that uh maybe 1415
we had internal staff we had we had you
know we like i said we had business
sector
we had ccea we had teach for america
we had um uh trustee cepeda said on the
commission
um business sector metro chamber
or las vegas chamber so we had a variety
and then obviously you know brenda
from ccn then we had some teachers as
well that'll be
included in the report great that's all
i have thank you
okay we're going to spanish language
univision
a
okay
[Music]
a
vacancies 264 274.
269 as of yesterday there you go so hey
alex
is
[Music]
okay again appreciate everybody taking
the time today
uh to sit and discuss
uh the commission's report that that's
released
feel free to email the communications
office if you need any additional
information
um thanks for taking the time today we
appreciate everybody and the work that
the commission has done
thank you